Before we dive in, a quick heads up. If you're a qualified psychologist in private practice, then Dr Claire Plumley and I would love to invite you to our next in-person event. It's the psychologist Christmas Social, happening in Kingscross London on Saturday, the 6th of December 2025. It's your chance to connect with other brilliant minds, enjoy some festive food and feel part of a real community, especially if you're missing that work Christmas due feeling. Faces are limited and feeling fast, so if you or a colleague might be interested, you can find the link to grab your ticket in the show notes or in my bio on social media or just send me a DM. Dr. Claire and I will look forward to seeing you there.
在深入探讨之前，先提醒大家一下。如果您是一位拥有私人执业资格的心理学家，我和 Claire Plumley 博士诚挚邀请您参加我们的下一次线下活动。这是心理学家圣诞社交聚会，将于 2025 年 12 月 6 日星期六在伦敦国王十字区举行。这是一个与志同道合的杰出人士交流、享受节日美食并感受真正社区归属感的机会，特别是如果您因为工作而错过了圣诞节氛围的话。名额有限且正在快速减少，所以如果您或您的同事感兴趣，可以在节目说明或我的社交媒体个人简介中找到购票链接，或者直接给我发私信。Claire 博士和我期待在那里见到您。
To many people, turning down a place on the doctorate in clinical psychology might seem unthinkable, especially after four rounds of applying, countless hours of prep and finally hearing the word yes. From the outside, it looks like the ultimate goal, the finish line, the thing you've been working towards for years. But what if that yes arrives at the wrong time? What if actually saying no is the most compassionate, values-led decision you could make? In this episode, I'm talking with Will about what it really means to walk away from a dream offer. And how doing so can shake up your identity, challenge expectations and invite some surprising growth. I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist, and if you're interested in honest conversations
对许多人来说，拒绝临床心理学博士学位似乎是不可想象的，尤其是在经历了四轮申请、无数小时的准备，最终听到“录取”这个词之后。从外部看，这看起来是终极目标、终点线，是你多年来一直努力追求的东西。但如果这个“录取”来得不是时候呢？如果说“不”实际上是你所能做出的最富有同情心、最符合价值观的决定呢？在这一集中，我将与 Will 谈谈放弃一个梦想中的录取通知书意味着什么。以及这样做如何动摇你的身份认同、挑战期望并带来一些令人惊讶的成长。我是 Marianne 博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，如果您对关于心理学、心理健康以及行业背后的现实的坦诚对话感兴趣，请务必点赞、订阅并关注以获取更多内容。希望您觉得它很有用。嗨，欢迎来到“有抱负的心理学家”播客。我是 Marianne 博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，今天我的嘉宾是 Will。Will 是一位助理心理学家。欢迎你，Will。啊，欢迎，是的。谢谢你邀请我。非常欢迎你的到来。所以谢谢你同意与我们交谈
about psychology, mental health, and the realities behind the profession, make sure you like, subscribe and follow along for more. Hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the aspiring psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist, and I'm joined here today with our guest, Will. Will is an assistant psychologist. Welcome along Will. I are welcome, yeah. Thank you for having me. You are so welcome to be here. So thank you for agreeing to speak with us
因为实际上你给我们提供了一个非常有趣且重要的叙述，因为你知道，你获得了一个名额，这对于许多人来说，以及对于过去生活中的你来说，可能感觉像是一个梦想，一个梦想中的录取通知书，是在一个你可能很熟悉的课程上
because actually you give us a really interesting and important narrative because, you know, you were offered a place which might for many of people and for you in a past version of your life I felt like a dream, a dream offer on a declines side course that was probably familiar to you
因为你在那所大学读过本科。但出于各种原因，主要是优先考虑你自己和你自己的真实生活经历，你在 2025 年拒绝了一个临床心理学博士的直接录取名额，对吧，Will？是的，我拒绝了。我拒绝了利物浦，我有两次面试。我有一次埃克塞特的面试，一次利物浦的。我收到了面试邀请，抱歉，是收到了利物浦的录取名额，但我拒绝了。这是一个极其艰难的决定，我相信我们会在录音的其余部分深入探讨。但这确实是一个非常、非常艰难的决定。正如你所说，过去的我，比如三四年前，这绝对是一个梦想。
because you'd done your undergrad uni at that university. But for a variety of reasons, mainly prioritising yourself and your own real life experiences, you said no to an outright doctorate clinical psychology place in 2025, didn't you, Will? I did, yes. I said no to Liverpool, to, I had two interviews. I had one for Exeter, one for Liverpool. I got an offer of an interview, sorry, offer of a place at Liverpool and I turned it down. It was an incredibly difficult decision, which I'm sure we'll plough into in the rest of this recording. But it was a really, really difficult decision. As you said, past life me, like three years ago, four years ago, like this would have been an absolute dream.
所以我读了本科。我实际上是在利物浦霍普大学读的，然后被利物浦大学录取了。是的，我只是，我爱那个城市。我爱那个地方。我在那里有朋友。但是，是的，正如我们所知，生活有它自己的方式鼓励我们做出不同的决定。而且，是的，我不会说这是一个容易的决定，因为事实远非如此。这是一个非常、非常艰难的决定。
So I did my undergrad. I actually did it at Liverpool Hope University and then was off to the Eaklin place as a Liverpool, UniOv. And yeah, I just, I love that city. I love that place. I have friends there. But yeah, as we know, life has its own ways of encouraging us to make different decisions. And yeah, I won't say that it was an easy decision because that is far from the case. It was a really, really difficult decision to make.
是的，但实际上，你知道，当我们得到感觉可能会改变人生的消息时，我也会邀请客户这样做。我们真的需要思考我们在身体的哪个部位注意到了这一点。你知道，我们对此有什么本能的体验。而且，你知道，获得一个录取名额，你知道，我有幸经常成为第一个被告知的人。他们给我发语音留言，他们说，天哪，Marianne，我得到了，天哪，我被录取了。听到这在他们的声音中意味着什么，你知道，了解他们并看着他们成长，并在那个过程中支持他们。然后他们得到了他们所追求的一切，一直追求的，他们认为他们想要的，这真是太不可思议了。
Yeah, but actually, you know, when we get what feels like might be life-changing news, I invite clients to do this as well, actually. We really need to think about where we notice that in our body. you know, what visceral experiences we have to that. And, you know, getting a declin side place, you know, I've had the extreme privilege of often being the first person someone's ever told. They leave me a voice note and they're, oh my God, Mary Ann, like, I've got, oh my God, I've been off in a place. And like, to hear what that means to them in their voice and, you know, to have known them and watched them grow and supported them through that process. and then them to get in everything they are striving for, have been striving for, that they believe they want, is incredible.
他们有那种融化、不知所措和喜悦的时刻。但你没有那种感觉，这非常、非常重要。这个消息是怎么传达给你的？你是怎么发现你被录取了，Will？是的，当时我在工作，显然收到了电子邮件，我只是坐在办公桌前，收到了邮件，我的第一反应是难以置信，我相信对许多人来说也是这样
And they have that moment of like meltiness and overwhelm and joy. But the fact that you didn't have that is really, really important. How was this news conveyed to you? How did you find out you'd been offered this place, well? Yeah, so I was at work, obviously got the email, and I'm just being sat at my desk and got the email through and it was just like my first response was like disbelief as I'm sure for many people is
说，是不是搞错了，这不是真的，这不可能是真的，然后想，天哪，我感觉到了很多情绪，我不确定我到底感觉到了什么。所以你去了洗手间，又读了一遍，觉得，哦哇，这是一个真实的录取通知。你谈到了那种本能的反应，有能量，有情绪
saying like said it's the wrong person this isn't right this can't be what this can't be possible and was like oh my god there's a lot of feelings that I'm feeling and I'm not sure exactly what I'm feeling so as you went to toilet and read it over again and was like oh wow this is this is a genuine offer and you talk about that kind of visceral response there was there was energy there was emotion
我感觉到了很多东西，然后那种似乎最能让我平静下来的感觉是那种恐惧感，就是，哦天哪，我真的必须做出这个决定，我必须和我的伴侣谈谈我可能要搬到四个小时路程之外，我将要把我的家人留在身后，我将不得不考虑住的地方，所有这些你知道在这些对话中真正起作用的事情，你知道，就像我说的，我在介绍中谈到的，你知道对有些人来说，新事物的想法
there was a lot of things that I was feeling and then the thing that kind of settled that seemed to kind of come through the most of me was this feeling of kind of just like dread of just like oh goodness like I've actually got to make this decision and I've got to talk to my partner about the fact that I might be moving four hours away and that I'm going to be leaving my family behind and I'm going to have to think about a place to live and all these kinds of things that you know really factor into these conversations you know like as I said like I'm talking through the intro you know for some people the idea of something new
远方的想法，这种所谓的“应许之地”和新朋友以及这类东西是非常有价值的，他们很高兴去尝试新事物。我想三四年前，那可能是我。但今天我处于一段稳定的关系中，而且，你知道，我年纪大了一点，我有其他我很高兴拥有并引以为豪且想要坚持的东西。是的，这就是我做出那个决定的原因，但最初的那种本能反应绝对是一种恐惧感、焦虑感，它根本不是纯粹的喜悦和兴奋，所以听起来这和你对其他人经历的了解不同，Will。是的，但你是一个不同的人，你
the idea of something, you know, far away of this kind of promised land and new friends and this kind of stuff is really valuable and they're happy to just go off and drop and try new things. And I think three, four years ago again, that might have been me. But today I stand in a stable relationship and, you know, I have, I'm a bit older and I've got another things that I'm happy to have and proud to have and want to hold on to. And yes, that's why I made that decision but yeah the initial kind of visceral reaction was definitely kind of their sense of of dread of of anxiety and it wasn't one of pure just joy elation yeah at all so yeah sounds like it was different for it has been for other people well yeah but you are a different person and you're
被允许有不同的体验，而且当我们做出选择时，你知道在电子表格上填写课程选择时，我们并不是真的在知情同意的情况下这样做的。你知道，我们想，哦，这应该是可行的，应该没问题。这与有人说，这是城堡的钥匙，但你必须搬到这里是不同的。而且实际上，因为我认为你的面试是线下的，我猜你最近有去那里的经历，知道那会是什么样子。而且实际上，那时你确实有了知情权，你有了更多的知情同意。而且，你知道，这会带回你已经在利物浦学习了三年的现实生活。但我猜，你知道，我们在培训时建立的网络
allowed to have a different a different experience but also when we're making our choices you know what to put on that electronic form for a course choice we're not really doing that with with informed consent. You know, we're thinking, oh, it'll be doable, it'll be all right. It's different than someone saying, here's the keys to the castle, but you've got to move here. And actually, because I think your interview was in person, I guess you'd had recent experience of making that trip and what that would be like. And actually, then you, then you do have an informed, you have more of an informed consent. And, you know, it would bring back the real life reality of, you having studied in Liverpool already for three years. But I guess also, you know, the networks
你知道，你会在西北地区拥有所有这些。那是对的，不是吗？是的，没错。然后当你获得资格时，你大部分的合格联系人可能会留在西北地区。实际上，你总是计划可能搬回西南地区。所以我确实认为你做出了一个非常明智、勇敢的决定，来尊重你自己并重新夺回控制权，你知道，你本可以做到吗？是的，你可以。我过去和那些搬离伴侣、远离稳定因素的人谈过，他们发现这极其困难，极其不稳定，这让他们想知道是否要退出课程，
we make when we're on training, you know, you'd have those all up in the north-west. Is that that's right, isn't it? Yeah, that's right. And then when you're qualified, most of your qualified connections would probably stay in the northwest. And actually, you would always be planning to probably move back down to the southwest. And so I do think you've made a very wise, brave decision to honour yourself and to take control back again, you know, could you have made it work? Yes, you could. Have I spoken to people in the past that have made a very big move away from their partners, away from their stabilising factors that have found it incredibly difficult, incredibly destabilising, it's made them think whether they want to quit the course,
这也包含了很多羞耻、指责和内疚，你知道，如果……会怎样，我不应该感恩吗？但实际上，你能够提前真正地思考这个问题，你说，不，我觉得这太勉强了，我向你致敬，我真的很感激。是的，并不是所有的反馈都是积极的，正如你所料，每个人都有自己的观点，完全有权拥有这些观点，其中一些很难听，其中一些很重要，比如听到其中一些东西真的很重要，但绝对地，我想你提到的关于稳定因素之类的事情，这真的帮助我在这项决定中站稳了脚跟，我觉得特别
which also has lots of layers of shame and blame and guilt and, you know, what if and shouldn't I be grateful but actually you were able to kind of really think this through in advance and you were like no I think this is a stretch too much and I I salute you for it I really appreciate that yeah like not all of the feedback has been has been positive as you as you might expect everyone's going to have their own opinion and totally entitled to that and some of it was was hard to hear and some of it was was important to hear like it was really important to hear some of that stuff but absolutely I think thinking you mentioned there about like stabilising factors and things like that and that was just that was really what helped to ground me I think in this decision that I feel particularly
在做出决定时感到脚踏实地吗？绝对不是，不。但那些帮助我的事情，你知道，围绕着这个决定，在做出那个决定时，你知道，我花了好几天时间真的只考虑这件事，我觉得我没有其他空间做任何其他事情，而那些稳定因素是那种决定以及我如何做出那个决定的一个非常重要的部分。向我的主管 Nicola 致敬，她绝对太棒了，非常支持我。她建议我做经典的优缺点列表。为什么不呢？而且还要给它们打分，满分10分。所以你评估了所有这些，然后把它们加在一起，再减去。所以你加上所有的优点，然后减去缺点。这就像，权重是多少？那是，
grounded when I made the decision absolutely not no but like the things that help me you know around the decision in in making that you know I spent a good few days really just really only thinking about this I didn't really feel like I had any other space for anything else and those stabilising factors are a really important part of that kind of decision and how I made that decision like shout out to my supervisor, Nicola, for being just absolutely amazing and super supportive. And she suggested I do the classic pros, cons list. Why not? And also then value rating those as well out of 10. So you've evaluated all of those and then you add them together and you minus. So you add all the pros and then you minus the cons. And it's like, what's that waiting? What's that? That was,
那太棒了。那真的很有帮助。因为这不仅帮助我做出了决定，它还让我思考我将要，你知道，真正列出所有事情。比如我实际上必须考虑哪些事情。对于我这样的人，你知道，我还有很多其他因素要考虑，比如我还有1型糖尿病，我必须考虑管理、更换全科医生以及获得药物的途径。这些决定也非常重要。还要考虑我自身潜在的神经多样性，那可能是什么样子，我可能如何适应，我可能如何，你知道，能够
that was great. That was really helpful. Because not only did it help me do like kind of make the decision, it informed that, but it also just kind of helped me think about all the things that I would, you know, really listing that down everything. Like what are the things I'm actually going to have to be thinking about. And for me as someone who, you know, I had a lot of other factors, I had other factors think about, which were the fact that I also have type 1 diabetes and I had to think about like what management and changing GPs and making trouble access to medication. Those kind of decisions were also really important. Also thinking about potential like neurodivergence within myself and what that might look like and how I might adapt and how I might, you know, be able
应对其中一些事情。就那些稳定因素而言，总的来说，就像我说的，比如我的伴侣，我真的很粘人。我喜欢拥抱。我不能撒谎，这对我很稳定，我喜欢那种抚慰和舒适的感觉，没有经常接触到这些，我只是知道那将是我会非常、非常想念的东西。不仅在我试图完成这门课程和试图做所有这些其他压力大的事情时会想念它，而且我也无法获得它来帮助我应对那件事。所以我认为这是两者的结合，比如想念那个人并造成痛苦，以及随之而来的任何事情
to cope with some of those things. And just generally in terms of those stabilising factors in particular, like I said like my partner, I'm very touchy really. Like I like cardals. I can't lie and that's very stabilising for me and I enjoy that kind of sense of soothing and comfort and not having access to that regularly I just knew that it was going to be that would be something I would really, really miss. Not only would I be missing it whilst I was trying to do this course and trying to do all this other stressful things. I'd also not have access to it as well to help me cope with that thing too. So I think it was the kind of combined of those two of like of missing the person and that creating distress and whatever might come with that
加上课程带来的压力，因为说实话，这很困难，这会很艰难，而且无法获得一些本可以帮助我更好地应对或以我喜欢的方式应对的事情。所以是的，无法获得这些东西对我权衡那个决定非常重要。是的，有时在我们的工作中，
along with the combination of stress from the course because let's be real, it's difficult, it's going to be hard and also not having access to some of things that would have helped me cope better or cope in a way that would have liked. So yeah, not having access to those things was really important for me in factoring that decision. Yeah, and sometimes in our work,
从一个在培训期间一直处于长期关系中的人的角度来看，有时我们说得太多了，有时我们需要伴侣的只是安静的陪伴，但他们就在这里，或者我们坐在沙发上，我们互相梳理头发，或者无论我们在看什么。这就是我们联系的时刻，而有时不得不打一个小时左右的电话或 FaceTime
speaking from the perspective of someone who's been in a long-term relationship whilst I was training, sometimes we're so talked out that sometimes what we're, need from our partner is just quite companionship, but with them like right here, or that we're sitting on the sofa and we're fussing each other's hair or whatever as we watch something. And that's our moment of connection, whereas sometimes having to be on the phone or FaceTime
感觉实际上并不一定是你想要做的事情，以在那个时候尊重你的自我保健。所以，是的，处于异地恋是一件大事。这是我们应该真正花时间考虑对我们自己以及对另一个人产生的影响的事情，你知道吗？在今天摄像机开始转动之前，我告诉你，我遇到了我的丈夫，我现在的丈夫，
for an hour or so feels like actually not necessarily what you want to do to honour your self-care at that time. So, yeah, it is a big deal to be in a... in a long-distance relationship. And it's something that we should really spend time considering the impact on ourselves and the other person as well, you know? I said to you before the cameras started rolling today that I'd met my husband, my now husband,
在我博士课程第二年的第二周。我告诉你，我绝不可能退出。因为，你知道，我真的很享受这门课程，我也很享受我的生活。所以当我们的关系很快看起来是可行的时候，可以说，我们不想分开，但我绝不可能搬到布莱顿。这根本不可能发生。
in the second week of the second year of my doctorate course. And I told you there was no way I was quitting it. Because, you know, I was really enjoying the course and I was enjoying my life. And so when our relationship very quickly looked like it was going to be viable, so to speak, it was like we didn't want to be apart from each other, but there was no chance I was going to move to Brighton. It just wasn't happening.
所以它几乎变成了一个，你知道，我不会把它作为最后通牒，但它几乎变成了，如果我们想在一起，而且我们现在想在一起，你必须搬家，我的朋友。所以这就是发生的事情。但是，你知道，如果他已经有了，你知道，取决于。已经有了，或者一份他非常、非常喜欢的工作，他是一名音乐家，他很享受那个，但他选择把所有的鸡蛋放在米德兰兹的篮子里并搬上去。但是，你知道，我们不是世界之王。我们不应该认为我们可以成为统治者，你知道，决定所有
So it almost becomes like a, you know, I wouldn't have given that as an ultimatum, but it almost becomes like if we're going to be together and we want to be together now, you're going to have to move my friend. And so that's what happened. But, you know, if he had had, you know, depending. already or a job that he really, really was enjoying, he was a musician, he was enjoying that, but he chose to put all the eggs in the Midlands basket and move up. But, you know, we're not the kings of the world. We shouldn't think that we can be the ruler, you know, that decides all
决定，仅仅因为我们有这个职业。所以，你知道，听起来你非常谨慎，是的，你做出了一个深思熟虑的选择，但我也意识到，如果你被录取到离家更近的课程，我猜你就不一定会有优缺点列表了，只会是毫无疑问地接受离家更近的那一个，我认为这本身就是信息，真的。是的，是的，确实如此。你是绝对正确的，如果我被埃克塞特录取，那会是，是的，或者普利茅斯，这也是我申请的地方，你知道，那绝对会是，是的，毫无疑问。我想那会，哦，那不是真的。会有
the decisions just because we have this career. And so, you know, it sounds like you're very mindful and yeah you've made a considered choice but also I'm aware that if you'd been offered a place on a course closer to home I guess it would have you there wouldn't necessarily have been the pros and cons list it would have just been hands down I'm accepting accepting the one that's closer to home which I think is information in itself really yeah yeah really is you're absolutely right if if I'd have been offered a place with Exeter it would have been yeah or Plymouth, which is where I also applied, you know, it would have been absolutely, yeah, complete yes, no questions asked. I think that would, oh, that's not true. There would have been
质疑，关于我完成课程的能力，我相信大多数人在经历这个过程时都会质疑自己。但是，是的，那会是一个容易得多的决定。而且，你知道，就像你说的，那是，那是信息本身。而且我认为向我最亲近的人解释这一点真的很难，这个过程，虽然我说不，但它确实肯定了，这确实是我想要做的，老实说，面试经历，随之而来的反思，很艰难，这是一个漫长的过程，但就像，仅仅是这个我目前担任的 AP 角色，在我的自尊和对我做这些事情的能力的信念方面，一直是非常有启发性的，抱歉，是塑造性的，而且
questions asked of, I think, my ability to do the course, as I'm sure most people would question themselves as they go through their process. But yeah, it would have been a much easier decision. And, you know, that's, like you said, that is, that's information in itself. And it was really hard to explain this, I think, to the people closest to me, that this process, although I said no, like it really affirmed that like this is really what I want to do like this honestly the the interview experience the reflections that came with it was hard it was a long process but like just generally this AP role that I'm currently in has been so informative in terms of like formative sorry in terms of my self-esteem and my belief in my ability to do this stuff but also just
然后显然获得了录取名额，也是塑造性的，就像，你知道，是的，我可以做到，我是，我是，我足够好，那个经典的问题。那只是，我无法解释，除了，那是一次非常好的经历。这就是我想要做的。这就是我想要做的。我知道这一点。而且这在某种程度上是一个非常困难的事情，我无法让人们理解，虽然这是我想要的，但我仍然说不，因为它只是感觉不是正确的地方、正确的时间，而且，你知道，我们谈论的其他事情。所以是的，那部分真的很有挑战性。我自己也在纠结，
then obviously getting offered the offer the place like was also formative and be like you know yeah I can do this like I'm I'm I'm good enough, the classic question. And that was just, I can't explain other than just, it was such a good experience. And this is what I want to do. This is what I want to do. And I know that. And that was a really difficult thing to communicate in a way that I could get people to kind of understand that like, although this is what I want, I'm still saying no, because it just didn't feel like the right place, the right time and, you know, of the other things that we've talked about. So yeah, that part was really challenging. And I wrestle with that in myself to be
就像，你怎么可能，你知道，你怎么可能知道这就是你想要的，你知道，即使你在说不，但坐下来思考过，有了空间，有了时间，反思过它。是的，这绝对是我想要做的。只是，它不是正确的时间。是的，好吧，不一定是正确的时间，但不是正确的地方，你知道。是的，是的，抱歉，是的，这说得通。因为我相信你仍然可以成为一个非常好的实习生，但我猜即使是，即使是你未来12年，不是12年，12个月及以后的经历。希望不会花12年，只会让你成为一个更好的临床医生和一个更好的人
like, how could you, you know, how could you possibly know that this is what you want, you know, even though you're saying no, but having sat with that and had the space, had the time, reflected on it. Yeah, like, this is absolutely what I want to do. It just, it wasn't the right time. Yeah, well, not necessarily the right time, but not the right place, you know. Yeah, yeah, sorry, yeah, that makes sense. Because I'm sure you still could have been a really great trainee, but I guess even, even the experiences you will have over the next 12 years, not 12 years, 12 months and beyond. hopefully it won't take 12 years will just make you a better clinician and a better human as well
而且当你成为一名实习生时，成为一个更好的临床医生和更好的人总是好的，是的，你会对自己、世界和他人更加富有同情心，我认为那是一件非常好的事情。好吧，绝对地，我真的很兴奋，就像在决定做出之后，有一种巨大的情感宣泄，你知道，有哭泣，有“天哪，我不知道我的人生该怎么办，这是我做出的正确决定吗”，我感觉到了很多事情，我相信大多数人都会有这种感觉，无论哪种方式，关于那个决定。但是，就像，一旦尘埃落定，在同一天，你知道，我和我的伴侣一直在谈论一起搬家，那意味着什么，那是
and it's always not it's always good to be a better clinician and a better human when you're going to be a trainee and yeah you'll just be more compassionate to yourself the world and others and i think that's that's a really good thing well absolutely i'm i'm really excited like there was after the kind of the decision was made like there was a big kind of emotional outpouring you know there was crying there was oh god i don't what i'm going to do with my life is this the right decision that I've made, there was a lot of things that I was feeling, as I'm sure most people would be feeling, either way, on that decision. But like, once that kind of dust settled on the same day, you know, my partner and I have been talking about moving together, what that meant, that's
我现在所处的，我们一直在谈论所有那些我们一直搁置的事情。对于拒绝，真的，那是我们没有做某些事情的主要原因之一。你知道，我们并没有真正计划太多的假期，我们也没有考虑，你知道，我们将如何管理，你知道，一起做某些事情和活动以及爱好，因为过去几个月我一直花很多晚上要么担心做这件事，要么在做这件事。我想担心可能是这两者中更多的那个。但是，你知道，很多时间只是被感觉和做事情所消耗。那真的非常令人解放。你知道，你计划了几个假期。你计划了我们打算去做的那些事情，你知道，
what I am now, we were talking about all these things that we'd kind of put on the back burner. For Declan, like really, that was one of the main reasons that we didn't do some stuff. You know, we hadn't really been planning too many holidays and we hadn't been thinking about, you know, how we would manage, you know, doing certain things together and activities and hobbies, because the past few months I've been spending a lot of evenings either worrying about doing it or doing it. I think worrying probably the more of those two. But, you know, a lot of that time is just consumed feeling and doing stuff. And that was just really liberating. You know, you planned a couple of holidays. You plan like things that we're going to go away and do, you know,
小小的度假，只是我们想多做一点的日常琐事。那真的，那真的非常可爱。你知道，我真的，我在那个时候对那个决定感到非常高兴，我想在时间方面也是，你知道，我想有几周那种泡沫，然后那个泡沫确实破裂了，就像，特别是通过这个谈话，你知道，我自己的咨询和反思之类的。一旦我开始给它空间，就像，哦，实际上，这确实感觉，它确实感觉像是一个巨大的损失。它，就像，它感觉像是一个损失，你知道，我们思考不确定性以及未来意味着什么，你知道，我不一定保证能通过筛选，获得面试，获得录取名额。
small getaway is just general kind of day-to-day stuff that we want to do more of. And that's just been, that was really, really lovely. You know, I really, I was so glad in that decision at that point, I think in terms of time as well, you know, I think there was a few weeks of that kind of that bubble and then that bubble did kind of burst and it was like, particularly talking through this, you know, my own counselling and reflecting and stuff. And once I started to give it space, it was like, oh, actually, this does feel like, it does feel like a big loss. It, like, it feels like a loss of, you know, we think about uncertainty and what the future means, you know, I'm not necessarily guaranteed to get through screening, to get an interview, to get off of a place.
你知道，这些事情都没有保证。我并没有认为仅仅因为我被录取了一个，我就绝对会马上被录取另一个。甚至在两、三年、四年后，我们都不知道。我并没有幻想那是真的。但那确实感觉是我当时作为一个人的最佳决定。那些我真正重视的东西，我绝对热爱我的工作。我绝对爱我的伴侣，我想留在这里，我想在这里花时间。我想出去做积极的事情。
You know, none of those things are guaranteed. And I'm under no impression of thinking that just because I've been offered one, that I will absolutely be offered another one straight away. Or even in two, three, four years, we don't know. I'm under no illusion that that is the case. But that just really felt like the best decision for me as a person at that time. Those things that I really valued absolutely love my job. I absolutely love my partner and I want to be here and I want to spend time here. I want to go out and do positive things.
我想继续提升自己。而且我内心也有一部分，我想，你知道，这些对话的主要部分确实是在提升自己。你知道，我是一个，你知道，自己与心理健康作斗争，发现事情相当困难，并且直到最近才真正与这种潜在的神经多样性的想法联系起来，你知道，与此联系并理解这对意味着什么。而且在糖尿病服务部门工作并自己患有糖尿病，就像是太棒了。老实说，这个角色太不可思议了。
I want to continue working on myself. And there was also a part of me, I think, you know, these main parts of this conversation was really working on myself. You know, I'm someone who's, you know, struggle with mental health myself and found things quite difficult and only really recently connecting with this potential idea of neurodivergence and, you know, connecting with that and understanding what that means for me. and also working in a diabetes service and having diabetes myself has been like just amazing. Honestly, this role has been incredible.
就像我对这个角色没有任何坏话可说。它太不可思议了，所有这些事情。但这里更大的图景是更好地了解自己，更多地与我的需求联系起来。而现在我内心有一部分，就像我也在兼职工作，一周三天，还有我在家里做的其他零碎事情之类的。那只是我内心的一部分，就像这些东西真的很重要。而且实际上这同样重要，如果不是更重要的话，基于我做出的决定，我会说可能比职业本身更重要。
Like I have no bad words to say about this role whatsoever. It's incredible and all these kind of things. But really the bigger picture here is this idea of understanding myself better, connecting more with what my needs are. And right now there's a part of me, like I'm working part of time as well, three days a week and other bits and pieces that I do around the house and things like that as well. That's just a part of me that just like this stuff is really important. and actually that's as important, if not more important, based on the decision I've made, I would say probably more important than just the career itself.
我不认为我准备好放弃我所有的业余时间。我相信实习生会告诉你，那不是他们所有的时间。我相信可能有些人会争辩说那是他们所有的时间，但那从你身上夺走了多少时间，以及它从你身上夺走的东西，当然也给了你，但我认为那是我现在还没有准备好放弃的东西，就我自己的空间而言。为了我的伴侣，为了我的家人，而且，是的，那不是我准备好放弃的东西。我认为这是值得称赞的，它也向我们展示了你想要这个，但你想要按你的条件来，而且你很重要，你的幸福很重要。你知道，如果你今年选择了那个选项，受打击的将是你的幸福。你知道，我认为如果有更多的大学提供这些名额，你知道，它会减轻压力，但我们知道，你知道生活并不完美，你知道，我们只是试图从区域上看看还有哪里有，嗯，提供的课程，你知道，在某个阶段
I don't think I was ready to give up all of my spare time. I'm sure trainees will tell you it's not all their time. I'm sure there might be some people who maybe argue that it is all their time, but how much time that that takes from you and the stuff that it takes from you as well as obviously gives you too, but I think that was something I just wasn't quite ready to give up on right now in terms of the space for myself. for my partner, for my family, and just, yeah, that wasn't something I was ready to give up. I think it's commendable and it also shows us that you want this, but you want this on your terms and that you matter and that your well-being matters. You know, it would have been your well-being which took the hit if you'd gone for that option this year. You know, and I think if there were more universities offering these places, you know, it would ease the pressure, but we know that you know life is not perfect you know and you know we were just trying to kind of look regionally at where where else there was um the office courses and you know and at one stage
曾经有布里斯托尔，但不再有布里斯托尔课程了，你知道，取决于你在国家的哪个位置，可能非常意味着你不得不几乎过度拉伸自己，去你打算通勤的地方，而且这并不容易，这并不容易，而且你知道，我搬到了考文垂，以为可能待三年，然后我会搬回米尔顿凯恩斯地区。有时那不会发生，你知道吗？有时你为了博士学位搬到的地方就是你最终建立家庭的地方。
there was Bristol but there's no longer Bristol course like you know depending on where you are in the country can very much mean that you're having to to almost overstretch yourself for where you're going to where you're going to commute and it's it's not easy it isn't easy and you know I moved to Coventry for what I thought would maybe be three years and then I I would move back to Milkkeen's area. Sometimes that doesn't happen, you know? Sometimes where you move for your doctorate is where you end up having your family.
那是我的孩子所在的地方。我的孩子现在是考文垂人了。它变成了你的生活。所以虽然我们可能会带着“我可以为此做三年”的想法进入它，但我猜最终我们需要思考，我可能想把这变成我的生活，你知道吗？不总是，不总是，但我们必须保持好奇心，并且必须有一些能力
It's where my children are. My children are Coventrians now. It becomes your life. And so whilst we might enter into it with I can do this for three years, I guess ultimately we need to think I would want to potentially make this my life, you know? Not always, not always, but we've got to be curious and there's got to be some capacity
为此，因为我们不知道生活会带来什么。是的，是的，那绝对是真的。而且我认为那是我想我也在努力甚至允许自己联系到这个想法的事情，因为我知道我绝对爱那个城市。我在那里有非常好的朋友，你知道，我是我的一位朋友在那里的婚礼上的伴郎，我爱那里，嗯，我说我也是利物浦的球迷，我喜欢音乐，我也是一名音乐家，所以身在利物浦对此也很好，你知道，在那里有很多积极的一面，我想这确实表明了它有多重要
for that because we don't know what life will bring. Yeah, yeah, that's absolutely true. And I think that was something that I think I was struggling also to even allow myself to connect to this idea of like, because I know that I absolutely love that city. I have really good friends there, you know, I was best fan at one of my friends' weddings up there like I love it up there um I said I'm a Liverpool fan as well I like the music I'm also a musician so being in Liverpool's great for that too like there's a lot of positives about being there I think this just really showed like how important it is for
对于我和我的伴侣，你知道那段关系有多重要，就像我说的，所有这些随之而来的联系和抚慰的事情，这太棒了，你知道，我不会，我不会想要没有它，而我典型的神经多样性大脑现在已经偏离了主题，我不记得问题是什么了，所以我们在这里。没关系。我不认为真的有一个问题。我想只是，你知道，当我们接受时，
for me and my partner like how important that relationship is and like I said all this connecting and soothing things that come with that which is just great like I wouldn't I wouldn't want to be be without and my typical neurodivergent brain has now gone off topic and I can't remember what the question was so Here we are. It's okay. I don't think there really was one. I think it was just that, you know, when we accept,
那可能更像是一个陈述，正如我丈夫会说的，当我们接受一个录取名额时，我们必须对这可能就是我们度过余生大部分时间的地方的可能性持开放态度。而且，你知道，那必须是可以的。我猜我也在思考我做出重大决定的经历。所以当我有点在应该全力以赴做自由职业者之间徘徊时？我应该离开 NHS 吗？我发现任何时候我有一个
it was probably more of a statement, as my husband would say, when we accept a place offer, we have to be open to the potential that this might then be where we spend the majority of our lives. And, you know, that has to be okay. I guess I was thinking as well about my experience of making big decisions. So when I was kind of towing and throwing between should I go all in self-employed? Should I leave the NHS? I found that any time I had a
空闲时刻，我都会试图权衡利弊。所以每次我去烧水壶时，显然在疫情期间，那很多，对吧？因为我们都在家工作。我发现自己做了那些优缺点列表，就像思考，我应该留下还是离开？我应该留下还是离开？这太累人了。这太累人了。确实。所以当我递交辞呈时，那应该是 2021 年 1 月，和你类似，我有了这种时刻，我不再需要做这个了。我不需要深思熟虑。我已经做出了决定，我有了这种欣快感，那时我感到从那个决定中解脱出来，期待着我选择的现实，知道我这样做是因为我决定了那些是最重要的原因
spare moment that I would be trying to weigh things up. So every time I went to boil that kettle and obviously during the pandemic, that was a lot, right? Because we're all working from home. I found myself doing those pros and cons list, like thinking, should I stay, should I go? Should I day should I go? It's exhausting. It's exhausting. It is. So when I handed in my resignation, which would have been January 2021, similarly to you, I've had this moment of, I don't need to do this anymore. I don't need to deliberate. I've made my decision and I had this moment of euphoria where I then felt free of that decision and looking forward to the reality that I'd chosen, knowing that I'd done that for the reasons that I'd decided were the most important
对我来说。这说得通吗？是的，绝对。绝对。这说得通。而且我完全能与那种欣快感的想法产生共鸣，我想一旦一切都安定下来，一旦我做出了决定，就像那些，就像我说的，那两三周的计划、积极性、感觉更紧密。因为就像有，它创造了这种脱节，就像，我可能会离开。我可能在几个月后就在四个小时路程之外了。时间，而且它们永久地，就像它可能真的很难，而且它总是有点挥之不去，它只是停留，你知道，而且那甚至在我被录取之前，你知道，因为你知道，归根结底，我们在 11 月提交申请，你知道，你不知道会发生什么
to me. Does that make sense? Yeah, absolutely. Absolutely. It makes sense. And I can totally resonate with the idea of like euphoria, I think once everything had settled, once I'd made decision and being like those, like I said, those two or three weeks of planning, of positivity, of feeling more connected. Because like there was, it creates this kind of disconnection of like, I could be leaving. I could be four hours away in a few months. time and they're permanently like it could be really difficult and it always just kind of lingers and it just stays and you know and that was even before i'd been off at the place you know because you know at the end of the day we submit applications in november you know and you don't know what's
直到你知道三月，所以这是很长一段时间的思考，你知道，有点深思熟虑，有一件事我想，我有点希望我做过，那就是考虑与我的伴侣进行那次坦诚的对话，并考虑，就像，这实际上是潜在的，这可能会发生，我想那是我避免的事情，因为我想对我来说那是自卫，就像，哦不，我永远不会被录取，让我们把它写下来，没关系，是的，不，我永远不会被录取，保护自己，没关系，我们不必担心那个，然后一旦你被录取，就像，哦哇，我真的应该进行那次对话，我应该谈谈那些实际情况会是什么样子，以及我们将如何管理这个，我想那会
going to happen until you know march so it's a long time of thinking and you know kind of deliberating and one thing i think that i kind of wish i guess i had done was to think about having that outright conversation with my partner and to think about like what like this actually is potential like this could happen i think that's something i avoided because i think for me it was self-defense it was like oh no i'll never get a place let's put that down it doesn't matter yeah no i i'll never get a place protect myself it'll be okay we'd have to worry about that and then as soon as you go off the place like oh wow i really should have just had that conversation i should just talk through what those practicalities are going to look like and how we're going to manage this which i think it would
让那个决定更容易。它会让其中一些事情已经被考虑过，而且我相信，对我自己来说，在一个不那么情绪化的环境中，也是如此。是的，所以这绝对是我如果这种情况再次出现，我会做不同的事情。而且我猜如果你还没有利物浦的经历，你可能不太可能把它作为一个通配符。所以这也许是，年轻的 Will 在某种程度上在帮你填写那份表格，但实际上是年长的 Will 不得不，好吧，那里，我们要夺回，缰绳，因为实际上那不切实际。所以，是的，就像，你知道，三个当地的课程，然后一个
would have made that decision easier. It would have made it some of this stuff would have already been thought about and probably in a less emotional environment for myself as well, I'm sure. Yeah, so that's definitely something I think I would do differently if that situation were ever to present itself again. And I guess had you not already had the experience of Liverpool, you might have been unlikely to put that as a wild card. And so it's maybe, younger will was sort of helping you fill that form in, but actually it was older will that had to, okay, there, we're going to take back the, the, the reins there, because actually that's not practical. And so, yeah, like, you know, three localish courses and then one
通配符。就像，好吧，那背后的动机是什么？除非，除非课程在做一些非常独特的事情，你知道，所以人们确实，人们确实选择国家中非常不同地区的课程，因为他们觉得，我觉得这些课程有点适合我，但我并不确定这就是这里发生的事情。显然，这是一门你很兴奋去做的课程，但地点可能，是的，基于年轻的 Will 和你与该地区的联系。是的，是的，绝对是。就像我说的，三、四年前，你知道，当我还在 20 多岁时，我想那仍然会是一个，你知道，一个我会跳进去的决定，而且会是一个我会抓住的机会。
wildcard. It's like, well, what are the motivations for that? Unless, unless the course is doing something very unique, you know, so people do, people do choose courses in very different areas of the country because they're like, I think these courses are a bit of me, but I'm not necessarily sure that's what was happening here. Obviously, it was a course that you'd be excited to do, but the location was maybe, yeah, based on younger will and your connections to the area. Yeah, yeah, absolutely it was. And like I said, three, four years ago, you know, when I was still in my 20s, I think that still would have been a, you know, a decision would have jumped at and would have been an opportunity I would have jumped at.
就像我说的，当我考虑在 11 月再次申请的决定时，你知道，我们必须再次经历那个过程。而且我想我内心有一部分仍然有点像，有一种梦想的部分，就像，是的，不，没关系。你可以，你可以申请利物浦，没关系。这绝对仍然像，我绝对承认那部分，因为我在那里有很多积极的经历，真的很难忽视，就像，我所拥有的情绪和经历，以及仍然在那里的朋友，你知道，所有那些
Like I said, when I think about the decision about making my application again in November, you know, we've got to do that process again. And I think there's part of me that's still sort of like, there's this kind of dream part of me of like, yeah, no, it'll be okay. You can, you can apply to live for it, it'll be all right. It's definitely still like, I absolutely acknowledge that part because there's so much positive experience I've had there, it's really difficult to ignore, like, the emotions and the experiences that I've had and the friends that are still there, you know, all those things
随之而来的事情，以及仅仅是你知道，我无法对面试过程说一句坏话，利物浦太棒了，如果有人在考虑它，就像会强烈推荐它，它非常包容，它很棒，而且你知道，所有这些东西真的很重要，但是的，我老实说，如果我真的非常坦诚，就像我不知道我在 11 月会做出什么决定，我可能仍然会申请利物浦，我可能不会，我想那将不得不是沟通，保持开放，看看我的自我进步在哪里继续，以及我处于什么位置，我们感觉如何，并在我把它写下来之前与我的伴侣进行一次公开的对话，那会是一个非常好的
that come with that decision as well as just you know I couldn't see a bad word about the interview process Liverpool are amazing like if anyone's thinking about it like would highly recommend it was very inclusive it was it was great and you know all of that stuff is really important but yeah I'm honestly if I'm really brutally honest like I don't know what decision I'm going to make in November I might still buy for Liverpool I might not I think that's going to have to be communication, being open, seeing about where my kind of self progression can continues and where I'm at and what we're feeling and having an open conversation before I put that down with my partner would be a really good
随之而来的还有那个决定，而且你知道，对于面试过程我真的说不出半句坏话。利物浦太棒了，如果有人在考虑的话，我强烈推荐，整个过程非常有包容性，真的很棒。你知道，所有这些都非常重要，但说实话，如果我真的坦诚相待，我不知道十一月我会做出什么决定。我可能还是会选择利物浦，也可能不会。我认为这需要沟通，保持开放的心态，看看我个人的进步在哪里延续，我处于什么阶段，我们的感受如何，在和我的伴侣最终决定之前进行一次坦诚的对话会非常好。
starting point I think. Yeah and maybe you know starting to have those conversations early as well so that you you can be excited about your choices as well you know so that you can kind of put those eggs in that basket but I guess thinking about placements you know we apply for a university, and certainly in my mind, you know, I was moving to Coventry and so I thought, well, I'm going to live in Coventry, my university's in Coventry and my placements will obviously be in Coventry. That is not the way universities work. In my case, I was assigned a base, an employment base, which was not in Coventry. And so that affected my mileage. I was actually
我想这是起点。是的，也许尽早开始这些对话，这样你也能对自己的选择感到兴奋，这样你就可以把鸡蛋放在那个篮子里。但我想在考虑实习时，我们申请大学，当然在我看来，我要搬到考文垂，所以我认为，好吧，我要住在考文垂，我的大学在考文垂，我的实习显然也会在考文垂。大学的运作方式并非如此。就我而言，我被分配了一个工作基地，它不在考文垂。所以这影响了我的里程。我实际上
given Warwick, which meant that whenever I had placements, I couldn't claim any mileage until I'd already gone more than eight miles or whatever it was. And so, you know, that's 16 miles round trip. And so that I was, I was financing my placement mileage because I wasn't able to make those claims. But your placement might be kind of within an hour, maybe in some rural areas, within an hour or a half of university, if you're already commuting, you know, they try to match you up fairly, but sometimes you might be an hour and a half the other side from where you're living. And we really, really need to be able to think about, is this going to be sustainable for myself, for my well-being? You know, maybe if you have problems sitting for long periods of
被分配到了沃里克，这意味着每当我有实习时，在我已经行驶超过八英里或无论多少英里之前，我都不能申请任何里程补贴。所以，你知道，那是16英里的往返路程。所以我是在自费支付我的实习里程，因为我无法提出这些申请。但你的实习地点可能在一个小时之内，也许在一些农村地区，离大学一个半小时，如果你已经在通勤，你知道，他们会尽量公平地为你匹配，但有时你可能在离你居住地一个半小时的另一边。我们真的，真的需要考虑，这对我自己，对我的幸福感来说是可持续的吗？你知道，也许如果你有长时间坐着的问题
time in your car. Is this going to be sustainable for my physical health? You know, can I afford to bankroll all this fuel? Like, we really must begin to slow down our reasoning process and not just get swept away with how exciting and how lovely it is to get this course over. We've really got to think about this being three years of our lives, you know, and I know some courses do part-time options. It can be, you know, up to four years and three months of our lives. Like, this isn't a short period of time and we must not gaslight ourselves or honeymoon ourselves into thinking that it's only three years because that's a significant period of time I think well yeah absolutely um scarcely to think about that would be 10% of my lifetime right now um thinking about spending away
在车里。这对我的身体健康可持续吗？你知道，我负担得起支付所有这些燃料费吗？就像，我们真的必须开始放慢我们的推理过程，不要只是被完成这门课程是多么令人兴奋和美好所冲昏头脑。我们真的必须考虑到这是我们生命中的三年，你知道，我知道有些课程有兼职选择。这可能是，你知道，长达四年零三个月。就像，这不是一个短时间，我们绝不能欺骗自己或沉浸在蜜月期中，认为这只有三年，因为我认为这是一个相当长的时间。是的，绝对，想到这一点，这几乎是我现在生命中10%的时间，想到要远离
from you know my partner from my life you know like like um as we were saying an intro you know I've born a bread in in Devon and Somerset so you know I had three wonderful years coincidentally you know in Liverpool and that being amazing but there is much more to life this is this really needs to be a holistic decision there's so much that goes into decisions around Declan and it's not just about your career it's about your relationships it's about your well-being. Also reflecting on that I think as a part of me that thinks I imagine there are some people who feel like it is just about the career and maybe they haven't been able to think they haven't been forced into making a decision or they haven't, you know, they don't want to think about it because they can just think about it
你知道，我的伴侣，我的生活，你知道，就像我们在介绍中所说的那样，我在德文郡和萨默塞特出生长大，所以我在利物浦度过了美好的三年，这很棒，但生活远不止于此，这真的需要是一个全面的决定，关于Declan的决定涉及很多方面，这不仅仅是关于你的职业，它是关于你的关系，它是关于你的幸福。回顾这一点，我想我的一部分认为，我想象有些人觉得这只是关于职业，也许他们没有能够思考，他们没有被迫做出决定，或者他们没有，你知道，他们不想考虑它，因为他们可以只考虑它
being a career and, you know, this, I feel like in my situation, for me, this really has made me think, like, this has to be a holistic, like, conversation because there is so much to do with, you know, adaptations and moving and living and paying rent and they say fuel and your placements and your friends and your family and all these kind of bits that fit together is you and your life and what that means for you. And, you know, at the end of the day, this is roughly speaking, a mental health course and it would be nice to think that we can also prioritise our own mental health in the making of these decisions and how we contribute then, I think also to the course itself. You know, I want to be able to give my best self to a course
是一个职业，你知道，我觉得在我的情况下，对我来说，这真的让我思考，这必须是一个全面的对话，因为有很多事情要做，你知道，适应、搬家、生活、付房租，他们说燃料和你的实习、你的朋友和你的家人，所有这些拼凑在一起的东西就是你和你的生活，以及这对你意味着什么。而且，你知道，归根结底，这大致是一门心理健康课程，如果我们在做出这些决定时也能优先考虑我们自己的心理健康，以及我们随后如何为课程本身做出贡献，那会很好。你知道，我想能够为课程贡献最好的自己
and I'm not sure at this time going to Liverpool would have been my best, the best version of me that I could have put on that course. And then that has its own ramifications, you know, itself may not have performed as well. You know, maybe I, you know, fail a couple of assessments or something. you get kicked off like you don't know or just maybe not as you've as spoken before like but maybe I don't enjoy it as much maybe you fall out of love with the work that you were doing and I don't want to do that I don't believe that it would happen but to say that it could never happen would be silly you know and I want to love that I want to enjoy it I want to be passionate and I can feel that like you know in my current role although my you know typical NHS
我不确定当时去利物浦会是我能在那门课程中展现出的最好的自己。然后这有它自己的后果，你知道，我自己可能表现得没那么好。你知道，也许我，你知道，挂了几门评估之类的。你被踢出局，就像你不知道，或者只是也许不像你之前说的那样，但也许我没有那么享受它，也许你不再热爱你所做的工作，我不想那样，我不相信会发生这种情况，但说它永远不会发生是愚蠢的，你知道，我想热爱它，我想享受它，我想充满激情，我可以感觉到，就像你知道，在我目前的角色中，虽然我的，你知道，典型的NHS
fashion my contract's up for renewal so that's obviously that's up in the air as well but the idea of like being here and myself I feel very much that this is me as a clinician and I'm able to bring that to my job and I love it and I like being here and I'm you know working on myself and those are all the things that I'm really happy to still have access to right now. Good good and you know you may you may choose not to apply to Liverpool and that's okay you may choose to apply to Liverpool whatever happens Liverpool can still be somewhere that you you know regard as an important place so my husband and I still like visiting Brighton and that will be always a special place because he lived there. And, you know, we can have mini breaks there
方式，我的合同即将续签，所以这显然也是悬而未决的，但在这里的感觉，我觉得这非常是我作为临床医生的样子，我能够把它带到我的工作中，我喜欢它，我喜欢在这里，我正在，你知道，提升自己，这些都是我现在仍然很高兴能接触到的事情。很好，很好，你知道，你可能选择不申请利物浦，那没关系，你可能选择申请利物浦，无论发生什么，利物浦仍然可以是你认为重要的地方，所以我和我丈夫仍然喜欢去布莱顿，那永远是一个特别的地方，因为他住在那里。而且，你知道，我们可以在那里度过短假
and love that. And yeah, like, you can still have that in your life, but it might not necessarily be that you live there full time again. I'm excited to see where your story goes and how it unfolds well. Thank you. Yeah, me too. Me too. Yeah, I've already signed up for the Liverpool Football Club tickets and stuff. So I'm looking to get tickets for this year. So yeah, I'm sure there'll be plenty of journeys up, if I can. So you want to be a season ticket holder? Not season ticket, just but like, you've got the ballot systems now? Oh my goodness.
并喜欢它。是的，就像，你仍然可以在你的生活中拥有它，但这并不一定意味着你再次全职住在那里。我很兴奋看到你的故事走向何方以及它如何展开。谢谢。是的，我也是。我也是。是的，我已经注册了利物浦足球俱乐部的门票之类的。所以我打算今年买票。所以是的，我相信如果可以的话，会有很多次旅行。所以你想成为季票持有者？不是季票，只是，就像，你现在有抽签系统了？天哪。
That was his whole own conversation, but I put in ballots for tickets. So, yeah, for the first half of the season. So hopefully we'll see that come through. My boys are Spurs fans and they're always like, can we get tickets? Can we get tickets? But it's so inaccessible because like you get the season ticket holders get first priority. And then, you know, it's just, it's really, it's not an easy thing to do. You know, it's a whole other episode, but it's not an easy thing to do.
那是他自己的整个对话，但我为门票投了票。所以，是的，上半赛季。所以希望我们能看到结果。我的孩子们是热刺球迷，他们总是说，我们能买到票吗？我们能买到票吗？但这太难获得了，因为季票持有者有优先权。然后，你知道，这真的，这不是一件容易的事。你知道，这是另一集，但这不是一件容易的事。
It is very expensive. as well. It's not easy and it's also expensive. Yeah, absolutely. Is there anything we haven't said so far that you think would be useful for us to talk about before we finish well? One of the prompts I was thinking about was this idea of having space for these kind of conversations in the profession. I think that is a really important part of this conversation where I feel super lucky, super blessed to have had like supervisors who are like amazing. Like I've loved by advice. It's like I've been incredibly lucky. I'm also very aware that not everybody has that experience. But in terms of space for these conversations, I'm not sure that there is some of that
它也非常昂贵。这不容易，而且很贵。是的，绝对。在我们结束之前，还有什么我们没说但你认为对我们谈论有用的吗？我正在考虑的一个提示是关于在专业领域为这类对话留出空间的想法。我认为这是这次对话中非常重要的一部分，我觉得自己超级幸运，超级有福气，有像这样很棒的导师。就像我喜欢我的建议。就像我非常幸运。我也非常清楚不是每个人都有那种经历。但就这些对话的空间而言，我不确定是否有
space for these kind of conversations. I've had people reach out to me via LinkedIn saying like, oh, like congratulations. Like I made something sort of similar and, you know, and saying that, you know, their feedback hadn't been very positive. And I think that has been quite reflective also in my own personal life where I've had people being like, oh, like that doesn't seem like the right decision. That doesn't seem like a good thing. the space for those conversations when i as i was reflecting on that i feel like that needs to be both bottom up and top down i think that needs to come both from ourselves as you know mental health practitioners whether it's be assistant psychologists psychological will-being practitioners whatever
这类对话的空间。有人通过LinkedIn联系我，说，哦，恭喜。我做了一些类似的事情，你知道，并说，你知道，他们的反馈并不是很积极。我认为这在我自己的个人生活中也很有反思性，我有人说，哦，那看起来不是正确的决定。那看起来不是一件好事。当我在反思那个空间时，我觉得这需要自下而上和自上而下，我认为这需要来自我们自己，作为心理健康从业者，无论是助理心理学家、心理健康从业者，无论是什么
to push for those conversations to be had i know we've got the infamous you know facebook um groups and everything which for me is too much i find that overwhelming not for me there's a lot of there's a lot of difficulty on that for me personally in that way but you know in terms of something in that space that can be helpful for some people but also thinking about bringing it into the workplace too because this is you know I remember being in an office in my first role in forensics and in forensic hospital and it was six APs in that office at that time that week of feedback where nobody got any interviews was just was just grim it was grim it's not a nice experience and reflecting back on it you know now like yeah we probably weren't ready
去推动这些对话。我知道我们有臭名昭著的Facebook群组和所有东西，对我来说太多了，我觉得那让人不知所措，不适合我，对我个人来说那方面有很多困难，但你知道，就那个空间里的一些东西对某些人有帮助而言，但也考虑把它带入工作场所，因为这是，你知道，我记得在我的第一个法医角色中，在法医医院的办公室里，当时那个办公室里有六个AP，那周的反馈是没人得到任何面试，简直太糟糕了，太糟糕了，这不是一种好的体验，回顾过去，你知道，现在，是的，我们可能还没准备好
and that's okay but ultimately thinking like it's not that experience is really difficult to have space for that it's a sense of loss it's difficult comes to a lot of different emotions for different people might tug on you know there's core values of not being good enough of overthinking of whatever it might be that it might be might be tugging on and then that was the case for me and to try and push to have those conversations whether it be in supervision whether it be peer to peer whether it be whatever, create that environment where we can have these kind of safe conversations about what that actually looks like and how that might impact, I don't know, our workload. It might be called talking about, I don't know, having some annual leave planned if you haven't got some planned
那没关系，但最终认为，那种经历真的很难有空间去处理，这是一种失落感，很难，对不同的人会引发许多不同的情绪，可能会触动，你知道，那些不够好的核心价值观，过度思考，无论它可能是什么，它可能正在触动，然后对我来说就是这样，并试图推动进行这些对话，无论是在督导中，还是同行之间，无论是什么，创造那种环境，我们可以进行这些关于它实际看起来是什么样以及它可能如何影响，我不知道，我们的工作量的安全对话。它可能被称为谈论，我不知道，如果你还没有计划，计划一些年假
already, or thinking about what we can do to, you know, create a space where we're working towards being able to get that offer, you know, the things that I need to work on and have that safe space to discuss that. And I know that's, that was all really helped me when I was in those conversations. That would have, that would have really helped, I think, at that time. And then thinking about top down as well is that I think supervisors, I think it would be really helpful as supervisors aware that I think of of the impact. I don't think there's many people that I've come across that aren't aware of how difficult this is and, you know, bringing that into their conversations. But I think that is an important factor of like just being aware of like those,
已经，或者考虑我们可以做什么来，你知道，创造一个我们正在努力能够获得那个录取通知的空间，你知道，我需要努力的事情，并有那个安全空间来讨论它。我知道那是，那真的在我进行那些对话时帮助了我。我想，在当时，那真的会有帮助。然后考虑自上而下，我认为督导，我认为如果督导意识到影响会非常有帮助。我不认为我遇到过很多人不知道这有多困难，你知道，把这一点带入他们的对话中。但我认为这是一个重要的因素，就像只是意识到那些，
those dates and the when people might be getting feedback and what might be happening and just being aware of some of those things, I think we're a really good starting point, but also just recognising that at the end of the day we are human beings and experience a cyclical experience of loss and of failure in parentheses, like it's not actually failure guys, don't worry, it's okay, there is another opportunity. But that experience, it brings up a lot of those emotions. And I think making space for that is really, really important. I know for me, in making decision, after the decision, before decision, talking it through with people, supervisors, friends, family, whatever, was such a good way just to get stuff out on paper, just to talk, just to make
那些日期，人们可能何时获得反馈，可能发生什么，只是意识到其中一些事情，我认为是一个很好的起点，但也只是认识到归根结底我们是人类，经历着失落和失败的循环体验，就像，伙计们，这实际上不是失败，别担心，没关系，还有另一个机会。但那种经历，它引发了许多那些情绪。我认为为那留出空间真的，真的非常重要。我知道对我来说，在做决定时，决定后，决定前，与人、督导、朋友、家人等谈论它，是把东西写在纸上，只是谈论，只是确保
sure you've processed, given a space and processed some of that stuff is really, really important. Yeah, thank you. And thank you for helping us to make space for that here. And actually, what I know is that this podcast changes lives. Well, people, because people get in contact and tell me that it has. Not always when they watch it for the first time, but that it starts to percolate ideas through for them. And actually, when it comes to key, decision-making moments, it's stayed with them and actually they think back as that as being a really pivotal moment. And maybe even when people begin to fill in their forms in future, they will hold this in mind and really think about the impact of, you know, which, which X's or
确保你已经处理了，给了一个空间并处理了一些东西，这真的，真的非常重要。是的，谢谢。也谢谢你帮助我们在这里为那留出空间。实际上，我知道这个播客改变了生活。嗯，人们，因为人们联系我并告诉我它确实改变了。并不总是当他们第一次观看时，但它开始为他们渗透想法。实际上，当谈到关键的决策时刻时，它留在了他们心中，实际上他们回想起来认为那是一个非常关键的时刻。也许甚至当人们将来开始填写表格时，他们会记住这一点，并真正考虑，你知道，哪些X或
which numbers they put in which boxes. And so thank you from me and from my audience for for helping us have this conversation because I think it's really important. It's really powerful than it matters. Yeah, I couldn't agree more. We do experience, like I said, other people and myself, that kind of idea of this pedestal for the Declan. And although it's something that I think we're all aspiring to, maybe not everyone who's in the audience, but I know a lot of people are aspiring to that. And is it great? Absolutely. Is it everything in the world? No, it's not. And your holistic self, your authentic self is really important. And like, I would encourage anybody to try and explore that as much as you can to bring that to your work, but also just
哪些数字他们放在哪些框里。所以代表我和我的听众谢谢你帮助我们进行这次对话，因为我认为这非常重要。它非常强大，而且很重要。是的，我完全同意。我们确实经历过，就像我说的，其他人我自己，那种关于Declan的基座的想法。虽然我认为我们都在追求它，也许不是观众中的每个人，但我知道很多人都在追求它。它很棒吗？绝对。它是世界上的一切吗？不，不是。你的整体自我，你的真实自我真的很重要。而且，就像，我会鼓励任何人尝试尽可能多地探索这一点，把它带到你的工作中，但也只是
your life. Just like be you, keep doing you. Like that's what's important. Make sure that you're happy and keep working on that. Because that's what we can do. Absolutely. Thank you so much for your time and for sharing your story with us, Will. Wishing you the very best of luck. And please do stay in touch. Keep us posted. All right. Thank you very much. Thank you. Thank you so much to our guest today, Will. Thank you for watching. Thank you for tuning in. If you would like to offer Will some support, please let's get busy in the comments and let him know that we really value him spending his time speaking with us. If you love being a fly on the wall of people's real life stories in psychology, I think you will love the Clinical Psychologist Collective Book. and the aspiring psychologist collective book too.
你的生活。就像做你自己，继续做你自己。就像那才是重要的。确保你快乐并继续努力。因为这就是我们能做的。绝对。非常感谢你的时间并与我们分享你的故事，Will。祝你好运。请保持联系。随时告诉我们进展。好的。非常感谢。谢谢。非常感谢我们今天的嘉宾，Will。谢谢观看。谢谢收听。如果你想给Will一些支持，请在评论区活跃起来，让他知道我们真的很重视他花时间与我们交谈。如果你喜欢成为人们心理学真实生活故事的旁观者，我想你会喜欢《临床心理学家集体》这本书。还有《有抱负的心理学家集体》这本书。
They get wonderful reviews and they really do help people to make sense of their own careers whilst reading and learning about people's reflective growth and journeys in their careers. They are uplifting, energising at times deeply emotional reads and I think that you'll really enjoy them too. If you've already read them and not yet left a review on Amazon or Goodreads, please do take a moment to do that
它们获得了极好的评价，它们确实帮助人们在阅读和了解人们在职业生涯中的反思性成长和旅程的同时，理清自己的职业生涯。它们是令人振奋、充满活力，有时是深刻感人的读物，我想你也会非常喜欢它们。如果你已经读过它们，还没有在亚马逊或Goodreads上留下评论，请花一点时间这样做
because it really does help audiences to know that it's worth checking out. And if psychology is a bit of you and it's your time and you're ready for the next step, please do check out the Aspiring Psychologist Membership and the Ready to Rise Program. Come and grab your free Psychology Success Guide on my website, wwww-Aspiring-psychologist.com.uk. There's also the free aspiring psychologist community on Facebook. which is one by me, Dr. Marianne Trent. If you're looking to become a psychologist,
因为这确实有助于听众知道它值得一看。如果心理学是你感兴趣的，而且是时候了，你准备好迈出下一步了，请查看《有抱负的心理学家会员资格》和《准备崛起计划》。来我的网站wwww-Aspiring-psychologist.com.uk获取你的免费心理学成功指南。Facebook上还有一个免费的有抱负的心理学家社区，由我，Marianne Trent博士运营。如果你正在寻求成为一名心理学家，
then let this be your guide. With this podcast, that's your side. You'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist.
那么让这成为你的指南。有了这个播客，这就是你的助手。你将走上获得资格的道路。这是Marianne Trent博士的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我的名字是Yana，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家非常有趣。
It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start.
它让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以到达那里，没有完美的途径成为一名心理学家。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，并减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，只是为了让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始，你就不会放下这本书。
Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。